the trumpet minutes to reopen safely
while the reported number of coronavirus
cases continue to rise Vice President
Mike Pence caused a bit of a stir
yesterday when he visited the Mayo
Clinic without wearing a required
protective mask Ben Tracy is at the
White House with more on this story Ben
good morning to you so what does the
president say about the u.s. reaching 1
million reported cases so far
well good morning late last night the
president tweeted that the only reason
the US has so many cases is because our
testing is so much better than other
countries but the u.s. now has four
times as many infections as any other
country despite that the White House is
moving on to what they're calling the
reopening phase with the president
focused on the economy at the White
House Tuesday president Trump defended
saying back in February that the US
would soon have zero coronavirus cases
well it will go down to zero ultimately
and you have to understand when it comes
to cases we do much more testing than
anybody else the president claims the
country will soon be conducting 5
million tests per day well we're gonna
be there very soon if you look at the
numbers it could be that we're getting
very close but we aren't the u.s. is
conducting about 200,000 tests per day
at a White House event to highlight
small businesses the president said the
worst of the pandemic is behind us but
without a treatment without a vaccine in
states now reopening how can you be so
sure
tremendous progress has been made we
think on a vaccine but I think what
happens is it's going to go away this is
going to go away but dr. Anthony Fauci
says if states rushed to reopen it won't
simply go away it could be a rebound to
get us right back in the same boat that
we were in a few weeks ago the mixed
messaging was on full display when Vice
President pence who heads the
president's coronavirus task force
visited Minnesota's Mayo Clinic Tuesday
he was the only person not wearing a
mask the federal government advises all
Americans to wear face coverings in
public and the Mayo Clinic added in a
now-deleted tweet that it had informed
the vice president of the masking policy
for the coronavirus on a regular basis
and everyone who is around me is tested
for the coronavirus the vice-president
is not alone when those mask guidelines
were unveiled here at the White House
earlier this month the president made a
point of saying that he would not wear
one and he often comments on people who
are wearing them at events here at the
White House anything Ben thank you